all right
welcome everyone
so we're gonna be talking about async
and await and i just want to make it
clear this is about c-sharp it's not
about javascript even though we have
async and awaiting javascript as well
this is about c sharp
so we're going to be talking about
efficient async and waiting going back
to the basics that efficiency can mean
quite a few different things depending
on who you're talking to it can mean are
we writing code that's efficient in
terms of is it maintainable is the code
efficient in terms of performance in
terms of memory allocations are we using
async and await and the task parallel
library in the way it's supposed to be
used so we'll be answering quite a few
of those questions today and hopefully
after this talk you'll have a lot of
refactoring to do in your applications
and maybe you've learned a thing or two
and my name is philip eckberg if you
have any questions after this talk just
ping me on twitter if there's anything
you want to know about c sharp or async
and await or just
talk in general i'm there just pinging
on twitter
so why would we want to bother
introducing asynchronous principles in
an application what's the purpose of
making
use of those libraries that we have
available in net and uc sharp
it really boils down to the fact that we
want to avoid applications that are
unreliable now this here is a sample
application that i built for android now
i'm not saying that all android
applications are unreliable but if i'm
the developer in some cases they might
be
so we can see here that the operating
system is telling us that this very
inefficient application is no longer
responding
we don't really know if the application
is doing something in the background
maybe it's occupying the ui thread to do
a lot of work that it shouldn't
we want to try and avoid this problem
here by introducing some some
asynchronous principles and maybe some
parallel programming as well to solve
problems a bit more efficiently
this also boils down to improving the
user experience we want to use
asynchronous apis and leverage all those
different types of apis we have
available to make our applications as
fast as possible
but we want to consume those apis
efficiently and that means consuming
both data as well as maybe web resources
or database calls and do that as
efficiently as possible
now
depending on where you're running your
code we have different amount of cpus
available or course available this is my
rather powerful workstation at home it's
a lot more powerful than what my phone
is today but i can almost guarantee that
in 10 years the phone is going to be
just as powerful
what's great about net and csharp is
that they're going to scale your code so
that it caters for all of these
different available resources that means
how much cpu can we use how many cores
are there available how can we split up
the work to make sure that the
application performs as good as possible
and when we're talking about
asynchronous principles and how to
write really efficient code it boils
down to two things
cpu bound operations or i o bound
operations
if we want to leverage the cpu and write
code that's really fast we want to use
parallel principles that means dividing
a problem in smaller pieces where all of
them can be solved independently we
don't really care about them
finishing in a certain order
for io bound operations that's
everything that's querying a database or
doing a web call or reading something
from your disk
so while we have these two different
principles one parallel paradigm and one
asynchronous principle they're kind of
work work the same way in dot net but
they are a little bit different and
we'll talk about that as well
what we really want to do here is that
we want to go from an application that's
blocking the user interface
to something that's no longer blocking
the user interface and to do this we're
going to introduce async and await we're
going to introduce the task parallel
library and we're going to try write
some code that's working really
efficiently
that means we want to avoid too much
work on the ui thread or the main thread
of the application
we may not be working in a ui
application but most of the time when we
want to introduce the task parallel
library or async and await it really
boils down to the fact that we have a ui
application that we work in we want to
make the ui a little bit more responsive
and allow the user to do more work while
we are doing some heavy lifting
now there's one thing i want you to keep
in mind and that's to avoid blocking
asynchronous calls or asynchronous
operations
if you ever have an asynchronous
operation running in your application
never try to force that to give you a
result without following the best
practices and principles
so in terms of that android application
that i had earlier that was rather
unreliable how do we refactor this to
give the user a little bit of a better
experience
this will result in is an application
that still
sort of blocks the ui
but in a rather different manner
to the left hand side here i have an
application where the operating system
notices that there's a lot of work
happening on the ui thread it cannot
determine if it's crashed or no longer
responding due to a deadlock or the fact
that we're doing too much work in the
wrong place
so instead we want to provide the user
with some better user experience with a
loading indicator
now for an for a web app or for a mobile
application it maybe don't make any
sense to allow the user to do more work
at the same time while this data is
being processed but for a windows
application that's a totally different
story
to solve this and approach this problem
and get a little bit of a better user
experience we're going to introduce the
task para library
this has been around for a rather long
time
it was first introduced in dot net four
so it's been there for a long time but
it's still one of those things that
tend to confuse developers
even myself learn things like past week
i learned something new about the task
parallel library and how to use that in
certain situations
so there's still a lot to to discuss
around this and how we how we approach
this it really means that
when we use the task parallel library we
use that to simplify working with both
concurrent as well as asynchronous code
so they group both the parallel
programming as well as the asynchronous
programming into the same library
there are some helpers in dot net that
allow us to take a problem and divide
that into smaller pieces using something
that they used to call the parallel
extensions and that's a part of the task
parallel library
now where they are different is where
with asynchronous programming
we can say that once you have all the
data available and you're done with your
work
i want to be notified that you have all
all that work done and i want to be able
to subscribe to when there's a result
available
and there's a very nice api in net or
a
library using the taskbar library here
where we can say that i want to run some
work somewhere else now i'm passing an
anonymous and or an anonymous method
here using a lambda but this could be
pointing to any method or anything in my
application that who responds with that
delegate
what this will do is that it will look
at do we have any threads available can
we schedule this work to run now if not
it's going to be queued up to run a
little bit later
so there's a lot of smart stuff
happening here in the background we
don't have to use the threading manually
anymore and we don't have to worry too
much about that
so the work is being distributed in a
rather efficient manner it knows how
many cores are available it knows how to
divide that across the different
threads available in the application
now
what's interesting with the task
parallel library is that it doesn't
actually spawn up a new thread always
it will have a pool of available threads
and they will be reused among your
different tasks that runs for your
different asynchronous operations
that means if you're working with static
data that may be may be available across
multiple different asynchronous
operations
so what to take away from that is that
you should avoid using static data as
much as possible
what it also allows us to do is to say
that i want to subscribe to whenever
this work is done
if i have this work scheduled on some
thread i don't know if it's going to
execute now i don't know when that
finishes maybe it's a long running
operation that never finishes but i
still want to be notified whenever that
succeeds fails or has a result available
that's what we where we introduce
something called a continuation
and the reason we have to know about
tasks in the task parallel library
before we even look at async and await
is because internally it all builds on
these principles
and the task of course allows us to
return data as well it wouldn't make
much sense to just allow us to schedule
work somewhere without having something
returned
now the the difference between these two
different um calls here
is that with the second one here i'm
simply saying run some work and when
this work is done i want you to return
some data and i and whoever subscribes
to whenever this work is done can then
get that that string back to them
so let's jump into visual studio and
have a little bit of a demo of how tasks
work
i have an application a windows
application that's
not really working as efficiently as
possible if i run this just to show you
exactly what the application is doing
you don't have to know anything about
wpf really you just it's just a ui
application with a button really when i
click run here it locks up i can't move
the window it's doing a bit of work on
the ui thread and i want to improve this
then it's printing something out to my
window here
the actual ui interaction isn't as
important as what's going on here
so because i'm running some work here
when i'm clicking that button i run this
method called do something
naming things is hard i try to come up
with a better name but
that's what it is so what's happening in
here is that we are just updating the
text we're then doing some or simulating
some work by introducing a thread.sleep
this could be a database called it could
be an operation or an algorithm that's
taking a bit of time maybe i'm using
bubble sorts to sort a really large
array you know i'm not following the
best practices here
so what i want to do here is that i want
to offload this work to somewhere else
and the first thing that you might try
to make this more performant if we just
make that smaller again is that we say
that i want to run this work
somewhere else
and i can say run all of this this this
method somewhere else schedule that work
to run on a different thread
if i run this
i click run here the application is much
better it it doesn't work actually
there's no result
that's a little bit odd isn't it so even
though when i click run here the
application behaves better it feels more
efficient but where's the result that
was supposed to come out to my window
here
now what's actually happening here is
that i i did offload this work so the
method is executing
but if i run it with the debugger
attached
you'll notice here that we are going to
get an exception because i'm trying to
update the ui from somewhere where i
shouldn't
so we'll see here that i got an
exception telling me that you try to
change the ui from a thread that doesn't
own the ui and you're not allowed to do
cross threading with the ui thread
so we have to introduce work to
communicate back to the ui and and this
is where it becomes a little bit hard to
work with because we have a few
different options here
either we go ahead and we
we do update the ui accordingly so we
could say that this is very very wpf
specific it's different for xamarin maui
and other types of platforms as well but
i could say that i want to update the ui
and to do that i have to communicate
back to the
ui and schedule some work on the ui
thread
we can do like this here
and then i'll copy this again
and of course this code isn't going to
be very efficient to work with because
it's not very
it's not very maintainable
let's run this here and see if it works
better
and look at that after two seconds now
hopefully it says hello
in dc from philip
so i made some changes to the
application i can click run here again
and i can move the window and everything
feels better i could allow the user to
work with other things in the
application
but there were a few things that
happened here that are
interesting and annoying first of all
the application didn't crash i wasn't
aware of that exception that i just got
here i tried to update the ui from a
place where i was not allowed to but
that exception wasn't really bubbled
back to the application
so maybe while a tester tests the
application they don't notice that
something isn't working accordingly
so
first thing the task will swallow any
exceptions that you get in order for you
to know that there was an exception
you have to subscribe or add a
continuation
so let me show you what that looked like
i can go back here to the top
and say that i want to continue with
some work
and in here actually this gets the the
task that's just completed
so i'd have to check in here if i got an
exception i could say that if the task
is faulted
i'm sorry
if the task is faulted i can do
something with that and now all of a
sudden the application is starting to
get much harder to work with and this is
the old approach before they introduce
async and await but we still have to
understand this because in some cases
introducing async at a weight might
introduce unnecessary code but we'll get
to that later on when we talk about what
actually happens when we introduce those
keywords
so if i throw an exception in this
method here just to give you an example
bro new
exception and we run this here i'll add
a
breakpoint
i'll click run in the application and
hopefully
this is going to throw the exception of
course since i have the debugger
attached it sees this exception and then
we'll be in this continuation here
and it's going to tell us that the
thread that we just completed faulted
and there's an exception available and
we can subscribe to that and we can
handle this
okay so what happened when we introduced
this continue with method here
let's uh make this smaller and just
think about what happened here for a
second so we introduced a continuation
to be able to subscribe to when work is
done
and that's pretty good but what happens
if this continuation fails
what happens if we have an exception in
this actual continuation
right if i do this through new exception
what happens if we do this
will that exception be thrown back to
the ui
let's give it a go and see what happens
i'll click run here nothing happens in
the ui nothing happens in the
application we didn't get an exception
thrown here
so
what happened here is that the
continuation is also going to swallow
your exceptions
and this is sometimes a bit confusing
so how would i capture that
well if we look at what the continuation
returns
we can see that this also returns a task
so how do i subscribe to when the
continuation completes
i add another continue with
all right
this code is starting to get really
efficient
all right so this is going to be the
continuation task that just completed
and what if that fails
i'll have to add another continue with
i don't really want to do that
i don't particularly like that approach
so the problem here is that
this pattern doesn't allow me to very
efficiently write the type of code that
i want to the coder starts to get a
little bit hard to maintain and hard to
work with while i still solve my problem
and i moved or offloaded some work to
somewhere else
it wasn't very efficient now i want to
show you an alternative way that we
could solve this if we just go back a
little bit here
i'll call do do something from this
method here and instead of
of offloading that entire method to a
different thread i'm going to go into
the root of the problem
i'll get rid of these exceptions and i
didn't particularly like this
dispatcher.invoke
i'll leave that as well the problem was
the thread.sleep here this is really the
work that i want to offload somewhere
else
so if i if i just wrap this in a
task.run
and i run the application it's going to
run the next line of code just
immediately which is problematic because
that's not what i want i'd like to run
all of the code whenever that
thread.sleep
finishes and to do that i'd have to
subscribe to whenever that continues or
whenever that completes
so i could say that i want to continue
with all of that
after this thread out sleep is completed
right
looks a little bit better but still it's
not the most beautiful approach and i
still have the the issue of what happens
if there's an exception and that's what
we're going to fix when we introduce the
async and away keywords we're going to
make this a little bit more more pretty
and beautiful
when i whenever i invoke the ui from a
different thread in a task or if i'm
using the old threading i always have to
go back or or use something called a
synchronization context which this here
the dispatcher builds on it inherits
from something called a synchronization
context which is what you use to
communicate back to that original
context
and i still have to use the
dispatcher.invoke here even if i'm
inside the continuation
because with the task parallel library
whenever you continue off the finished
task you will be on a different thread
you never know which thread you are
going to execute on
maybe if you're lucky enough it would
actually reuse the ui thread but that's
very unlikely actually it's never going
to happen but
in theory it could so
we want to avoid this here and we have a
few more problems that we can we're
going to approach when we've introduced
the async and away keywords
so that's a little bit of background to
the the tasks and how you how you work
with them there's a few considerations
to take away from this here one is that
we should be really careful when we wrap
code or wrap method calls in a task.run
instead we're gonna we should try to do
what i did in the second part of this
demo here where i went into the root of
the problem i found what was causing the
application to be slow and that was in
this case a thread.sleep so i wrapped
that particular call inside my task.run
and i try to make my code a bit more
asynchronous or or parallelize it if you
like
and again
we didn't look at this but you should
keep in mind that whenever you work with
thread static data
that is very unreliable as you could be
reusing threads across the thread pool
there's something else you can use and
that's async local all right so
another thing to to leave you with here
is that we should always validate the
tasks so as you saw here the task will
swallow all your exceptions and you
wouldn't know that there was an
exception unless you subscribe to it
unless you add a continue with you won't
know if there was a fault state
so we're going to fix this using async
and await
and before we look at async and wait i i
did mention earlier that
parallel extensions that are also
available in net that we have here
so the parallel.4 here this builds on
top of the task parallel library what it
will do when i run parallel.4 here it
will look at how many cores are
available or how many threads are
available and i can configure that to
for instance only use two threads to not
consume all my resources if i don't want
to do that
and the reason this is wrapped in a
task.run is because it also uses the
current thread to do its operation it's
a blocking call
so if you use parallel four or parallel
for each or parallel dot invoke that's
going to block the current thread until
that operation completes
so this is a way to i would say combine
asynchronous and parallel principles
so you could say run this parallel
process on a different thread or
multiple different threads and let me
know when there's a result available
all right so enough talking about the
task parallel library and only using the
task the raw state that we've looked at
let's now introduce the async and await
keywords
these are really just synthetic sugar or
rather contextual keywords that means
that they are looking at your method and
looking at where you place the keywords
in the code and it's going to rewrite
your entire application so to speak or
the method that you add it to it's going
to add a lot of generated code behind
the scenes
and depending on who you ask
some say that it doesn't really matter
and if you're working in iot or really
small let's say raspberry pi's or
something that's very very
or that energy that needs to be energy
efficient for those developers it
certainly does matter you want to make
sure that the application runs
efficiently and in some cases that means
not introducing async n08 at all
because generated code means that it's
going to require more cpu power more cpu
power means more battery and so forth
so async can await really what they're
doing or the purpose is to hide
complexity
i would say that even if this was a very
simple example that i showed with the
task parallel library it looked a bit
complex it looked more complex than it
had to
i really just wanted to say that take
this piece of code or run that somewhere
else and then run the rest of it when
that's done there has to be a better way
to do that and obviously async and await
is the answer to that
it also is built for readability we want
to make sure that the application is
maintainable and more readable
but that also means that it's going to
be more error prone if we don't fully
understand the tasks parallel library
how it works with the continuation works
on a different thread or that it
swallows exceptions
the async and away keywords is not going
to help you it's going to make it even
more confusing
i've seen many projects or many
developers just use async and have it
all over the place in some cases it just
works it's it works just as they expect
to
but when it doesn't it's very confusing
and can be very hard to understand why
it doesn't work as expected
let's take this very simple method as an
example
now the first thing you'll notice here
is that i've increased the async keyword
when i do that
you notice that i don't have to return
anything from this method that's
automatically taken care of by the
compiler and that's to allow me to track
the state of the current asynchronous
operation but marking this as async
doesn't have any impact whatsoever on
where the work is being executed or what
happens
adding async simply just wraps my entire
code somewhere else it introduces
something known as a state machine that
we're going to look at later to fully
understand the complexity
so always use async and task together
and then when you want some asynchronous
operation introduced in that method you
have the await keyword in front of
whatever operation you are waiting to
finish or waiting to complete
now the await keyword here is is in
front of your task this is the task that
delay which is kind of equivalent to
doing a thread.sleep and wrapping that
in a task.run it just simulates that
some operation could be a web call could
be reading something from disk or some
other asynchronous operation
the await keyword here when that is
introduced it knows how to run the rest
of the code after this line
and come back to that whenever the
asynchronous operation is completed
so actually what the away keyword does
is that it marks a continuation instead
of having to wrap that entire code block
in a continue with it just takes care of
that for us
but i guess what's even more interesting
is when it comes to how do we make sure
that we validate the tasks and that they
complete it successfully
this is also handled by the await
keyword it will validate that you have a
success or failure if there is an
exception in any of the tasks that you
are waiting for or awaiting
it will tell you it will throw that
exception back to whoever calls that
method and it then returns back to
whoever calls method and this is where
it becomes a little bit more confusing
so whenever it sees the await keyword
and it's waiting for an asynchronous
operation to complete the control is
returned back to whoever called the
method
that means that they can continue doing
some work and then when this
asynchronous operation is completed it
will schedule that continuation to
execute
you should always aim to use the async
and await keywords together
you cannot use the await keyword alone
but for some reason you can use the
async keyword alone which doesn't make
any more any sense at all
it simply just introduces complexity
so let's have a look at how we can
improve the code that we had earlier
by introducing async and await
so there are a few things that we want
to do here
to make this a little bit better really
i want to get rid of this dispatcher
here and i want to make sure that
whenever there's an exception i want to
be able to validate that that didn't
happen
so we have a few different options
either
if we if we go back to
we'll remove this continuation because
we don't need that anymore the result is
what's going to come out of our
asynchronous operation let's just
imagine that after thread.sleep this
here is going to be returned
so i'm going to refactor this just
slightly to give you an idea of what's
going to happen here
so let's say return hello from philip
and really what i want to do here
let's get rid of all of that
really what i want to do here is that i
want to run this code block here
somewhere else and when that is done i'm
going to get some data back
so i guess the first question is how do
we get the data or the result out of
that asynchronous operation
well i can capture the task that's
executing
to say that give me the the task
and then i could say
task.result which is one of the first
thing people tend to do and this is
where things blow up because this is
going to in most cases deadlock
it's going to lock the application so it
doesn't work anymore
and the reason for that is because
calling dot result is a blocking
operation you should only call a result
whenever you know that the asynchronous
operation completed
which can be tricky
so how do we get the result out of this
task in fact this is where we can
introduce the await keyword
so we can say
await
the task
this will do a few things it will
validate that the operation completed
successfully it will make sure there
were no exceptions and it will also give
us the result so we can capture this in
a local variable
and then we can set that to the ui
so far this looks much better than what
we had earlier
and what's going to happen here is that
we are starting off as a sequence
operation
this operation starts off and it runs on
a different thread for two seconds after
those two seconds are completed we are
going to be back at this line here to be
able to update the ui
so how come i don't need the
dispatcher.invoke anymore because what
the await keyword also does is ensure
that we are back to the original calling
thread
i can configure that to tell it to just
continue working on the other thread by
introducing a configure await
which is what you might do in apis if
you don't care about going back to the
original thread
but we don't have to talk about that
because it gets a little bit confusing
so now
i've introduced the the the await
keyword but i've also already made this
async that's quite work um sorry
the async keyword should also be be
added here at the top
so i have the async and the weight
keywords together and i did mention
earlier that i do want to always have a
task here because if i use async void
this may cause some issues that we're
gonna look at later on as well
just trust me that it's not a good idea
to do async void
so now i've marked this as asynctask we
have some asynchronous operation running
somewhere else and it's going to return
back to the caller whenever those two
seconds are up let's actually increase
this to five seconds just so i can
illustrate exactly what's going to
happen here
so now whoever's calling this here
we are returning a task here
automatically which is a way to track
the asynchronous operation in reality
it's a way for me to track whenever that
thread.sleep is completed or that
operation that i've offloaded somewhere
else
so the async keyword introduces a way
for me to track this and automatically
returns this task for us
so in order for us to validate this the
the visual studio here will tell us that
this here should probably be awaited
because it returns a task if we don't we
might not want to do this we might want
to do a fire and forget and to get oops
sorry and to get rid of the the compiler
warning we can discard that to simply
say that i don't care just run this and
i don't really want to track this work
at all
this is the same as saying i don't care
if there's any exceptions just run the
task if it completes fine if it doesn't
who cares
but i care
so the way that i need to approach this
is i need to introduce the await keyword
to await this
but to do that
i also have to add the async keyword
and since this is a delegate that needs
to correspond with the click event
handler i cannot change this to a task
right
then my application will no longer work
let's keep this as async void for now
the only purpose where you would ever
use async void is for click event
handlers
all right so if we if we
if we run this actually let's do this
for
task is equal to this
and then let's do debug.text
plus equals to updating
or loading
and then we'll do away task
so now we are going to start off do
something we're going to grab that task
and that's going to run somewhere else
then i'm going to update the ui and
we'll see what happens when we step
through the application
i'm going to click the button
it's going to get rid of all of this
noise here
let's go into do something let's click
down here
now we're going to start off this five
second work to run somewhere else
and now we see the await keyword and
notice what happens when i step to the
next line here actually it let's do that
again
i need another
i need another breakpoint
let's click run let's go into this
method step through this it sees the
weight keyword and now what happens is
that it's going to go up to run this
line in the previous method that called
this here
so until it sees the await keyword it
doesn't wait for that to be done using a
weight doesn't mean that it waits in
this particular spot until that's done
it means that it schedules a
continuation behind the scenes it's
going to also capture the current thread
it's going to use that capture thread to
then schedule work back on that original
thread so if i press f10 here after
about five seconds
hopefully after five seconds this is
going to complete and it updated with
that result as well
just to show that again let's click run
go into the method
run through this here
awaits that and then after that is done
it goes back and updates the ui and
everything worked without any
dispatchers and or any cross threading
that i had to do at all now if i were to
introduce this con configure await
method call that you might see a lot of
people
recommend doing i would have a lot more
issues this application wouldn't work as
as expected because that would mean that
i don't care about which thread i'm
coming back to so just keep that in the
back of your head that whenever someone
recommends you to add configure await
that's where you don't care about
updating the ui or you don't care about
the the original thread when you're back
in the continuation
so this code here honestly this code
looks a lot better than what we had
earlier
and
i also mentioned that this will allow us
to validate that there was a wasn't any
exceptions so what happens if i throw an
exception here
throw
new exception
of course if i run this with the
debugger
hopefully the application is going to
crash
click f5 here
and we can see here on the await task it
knows that this through an exception
so it's only when i do a wait that it
validates that that operation completed
successfully and then here what what
happens here is that it's going to be
thrown back to whoever called the the
click event handler which is the ui
which means that the application crashed
so could of course now add a dry catch
around this and just make it a little
bit better and tidier
but let's leave it like this for now
and let's go into talking about the the
state machine
i think it's important to understand
what happens internally when we
introduce these keywords and what
happens when we introduce the async
keyword is that it generates one of
these things called a state machine it's
really just a way to ask if we are
completed
it's not a loop that continuously
continuously checks if we are done it's
really smart internally because it
schedules itself onto the next
continuation so it runs in a synchronous
operation then adds itself to whenever
that is done and then it checks the
status and goes on to run the next
asynchronous operation in line that
means that we could have multiple tasks
in the same method we could have
multiple awaits
all in the same place and the state
machine would take care of running all
of those at the appropriate time
it's also what really handles the
potential results and the potential
problems
so all of that is being handled
internally and it also makes sure that
the code after the await keyword is
executed on the proper thread it makes
sure that it executes the proper i guess
the proper continuation at the right
time
so then the async keyword what does that
really do well it does generate this
state machine which means that it moves
the entire method body
and it kind of obfuscates that if you
would in a completely new class that
handles all of these different states
so if we again look at this very simple
example which is a pre-compilation i
haven't compiled the application
it's a very simple application it
declares a variable called x has a task
a delay again could be anything
and then in the continuation after the
await keyword we are asking to be back
at the original thread on the thread on
whoever called run async it's that
thread that we want to be back on
there's nothing in this code here
that is running on another thread so
even if i have
the test of delay that's the first thing
that's being spawned off to a different
thread
and when i compile this we can see here
that there's nothing here that starts a
thread there's nothing here that's just
moving
moving work to another place right
we have some generated code this is the
generated state machine that runs but
all of this runs on whoever calls this
this method
so if you have slow code inside this
method here
it's still going to be slow even if you
add the async and the weight keywords
you have to manually move that across to
a different thread
so this here looks very different from
what we had in in that pre-compilation
version
it generates a state machine look here
at the bottom where it says
that we can return this
state the state machines task which is a
kind of a way to track that work
so it just takes care of all of that for
us and if we drill down into the
implementation details of how this works
we're not going to be rebuilding the
state machine because that doesn't help
anyone but we can at least have a little
bit of a look at one of the places
inside one of the methods that keeps
track of this date
so we can see here that we have the
variable declaration
we have the task.delay
we have the we have a call here that
says if you're not completed just return
and it's going to add itself onto the
next tasks continuation
so really what it's doing is that this
task a delay here
this here it gets this a waiter and then
it adds itself onto that continuation to
run the state machine again whenever
that is done
somewhat like that it works which is
very clever
and then at the bottom here we can see
that we have our debug.writeline which
is going to be executed on that original
thread
so the state machine is really clever
it's trying its best and while this is a
very simple example we just want a
weight keyword
if we add more weights if we add more
tasks in the same method this here is
going to grow quite a lot
we can take a look at that soon
now i've mentioned that we should avoid
async void
and it is really bad like i i i can't
stress enough how bad it is to use async
void in your applications
because what happens is that
in this case here how would we ever
track the work how would we ever know
that the application
that this this operation completed or
not
like when i compile this here there's
nothing that's returned from this method
to allow me to track that the state
machine finished properly
so what does the state machine do if
that asynchronous operation that it's
tracking fails
well
to say the least if i ever drive a car
built on.net that uses async void
don't put me in that car please
because if that fails we're going to end
up having a disaster in the application
so how do we fix that it's a quite easy
fix but it means that we architecturally
need to think a little bit more about
how we consume those methods
because we need to change async void to
async task and while this change was
rather simple
it makes a little bit of a difference in
the application because now this might
swallow an exception
anyone that's using this method now has
to track that this work completed
successfully so let's look at how bad
this is
let's have a little bit of a look
so if we if we make one simple change in
the application let's say that instead
of this method do something being
asynctask i can change this to async
void and while this method still works
you'll see here at the top
that since this doesn't return anything
it doesn't make sense to try and capture
the return value
and then i can't await that
and how would i then
know that something that all of that has
completed successfully
of course if i run the application you
might expect that it's going to crash
and that's exactly what's going to
happen
now one of the first things most
developers do when they have an
exception what's that it's adding a
trying catch block
if i do that
hopefully
a pokemon cachamol is going to work
is this going to work
yes no
it didn't work
the application still crashes
so is that odd is this what we would
expect i wrap my entire method call that
i know has an exception in it i wrap the
name i try and catch block
but since all of this code here is sort
of changed it doesn't matter that this
is async by the way
the problem is that the method do
something is marked as async void
because what happens is that the state
machine doesn't have a way to notify
anyone that there was an exception
so what's the best way to solve that
it's just to tear down the application
just crash everything that's probably
what the developer wants
probably not
i don't know how to how they would have
approached this differently but
anyways it's it's it's what it is and
this is why we should avoid async void
there's no way to recover from this
there's no way to capture that i believe
we could monitor for unhandled
exceptions but the application is still
going to crash so the way that we solve
this obviously is to change this back to
asynctask which then means that we need
to introduce the await keyword
which means that we need to mark this as
async void
this is the only place where you are
allowed to use async void that will
click event handlers or delegates that
require that
so how do we avoid
this problem with that we just had that
applications crashes due to unhandled
exceptions
the easiest way is to write code that
doesn't crash
but i don't think that's a good idea
either because that's not going to
happen so avoid having too much code
inside your async void methods this is
probably the the best approach or the
best
alternative in this case here is to have
a try catch for all of the code inside
your async void method
ensure that there's nothing that could
potentially throw an unhandled exception
catch all of it and try to handle all
the exceptions in an async void method
don't have code that could crash
so
this here will now allow us to capture
this exception and of course if i put a
breakpoint in here i can now catch this
as we saw earlier
just to validate that this works
we can see that we are now catching this
exception again just by changing it to
asynctask but we also changed the way
that this is consumed so if you start
off building an application or
refactoring an old application where
some someone introduced async void and
you're changing that to asynctask it may
now swallow the exceptions so you need
to keep that in mind
so let's now talk about that state
machine right so
this here as i mentioned earlier
is going to
let me just
reopen this here we
go perfect visual studio doesn't want to
work with me
i think i have this open here
so for every method that you have marked
as async it's going to generate one of
these state machines now i have a
a rather simple console application as
of i believe c sharp 7 you're allowed to
do async async main
which is nice
and the reason you would use an
asynchronous principles for that in
console applications even if there's no
ui it's because you might share apis or
share frameworks or new get packages
where they only expose asynchronous apis
so in this case here again naming things
is hard but i have a method called run
async which is then calling run internal
async which is then calling something
internal async now of course this looks
silly but it happens quite a lot you
have services layers you have factories
you have all of these different you know
you're on an architecture where you have
multiple different layers where each
method call is an asynchronous operation
and what you do when you see an async or
a task return from a method is that you
increase the await keyword because
you've been told that you should do
async all the way which means you should
always introduce the await keyword
which you shouldn't
and i'll show you why
in this case here
for this uh this method here at the
bottom
now we could probably improve on this a
little bit here
we have two things that's that's could
be potentially improved here
one is that this is the first time we
see two awaits being used in the same
method and that's totally fine
but what happens here is that we are
starting off in a synchronous operation
and then i have the await keyword which
indicates that i'm not starting the
second one until the first one completes
now in a better way i would want to
start these at the same time because
these two doesn't have anything to do
with each other but i'd still like to
wait for them both to complete
and this is where i can introduce
something
called task
dot when all
you should not confuse this with weight
all or wait any because this here will
definitely deadlock your application
so if i do task.when all this is a way
for me to pass a params of tasks
they all start at the same time
and now what happens here is that i have
a way to track that all of these
completes
before i execute the next line
if i do this here so now i'm saying that
run both of these the sequence
operations at the same time let me know
when all of that completes
i could also say just let me know when
one of them completes but that's for
other types of purposes
so
that's one improvement that i've made
now but still i have the async in and
await keyword and the question i guess
is do we need that in this case here
if i compile this application
and i go into an application called il
spy
look look at this here this here
generated
one state machine per method that is
marked as async it's using the await
keyword
what does that mean well it means that
we have quite a lot of code and all of
this code here if i just expand on all
of this here it doesn't look like it's
much but honestly it's more code than
what we would need to
right this is for each method that's
marked as async
and for iot devices
each each line of code is a lot it's
like it's that drains battery and that's
true for android phones and ios devices
if you're using
dot and maui or xamarin right
so do we need to introduce a state
machine
that's kind of a leading question we
don't
in this case here i'm not doing anything
like i can remove this portion of the
code here because that's just
a reminder and now visual studio crashed
what i can do is that i can remove the
code at the bottom
let's uh let's do this
see if that works better
yeah whatever
all right
here we go
instead of having the await keyword here
i can still follow the same pattern
because when this is compiled
the async keyword is no longer available
in the compile code right so
all that i need to do is ensure that i
return a task
if i replace the await keyword with a
return and remove the async keyword i
still have the same
the same signature for the method i'm
still doing the same thing but what i've
done now is that i've reduced one state
machine and i can do this for for each
method where i don't do anything in the
continuation
and all of a sudden we have quite a lot
of code that's
that's reduced it's no longer
requiring to
to generate all of that code and i can
even do it in this method that looks a
little bit more complex this here is
running that run internal async it's
then appending a continuation to that
and what i could do is that i can can
return that
like this here
now
when i had oops sorry
here we go when i return that
continuation that's actually both the
original task and the continuation
appended to it so it will ensure that we
can track all of that
so where do i need the async and await
keywords well
when someone says you need to use async
and await all the way through it's it
means that you should use async and
await and not don't block your
asynchronous operations don't use dot
weight or dot result anywhere in the
chain of asynchronous operations we
should await it at the top level
for instance in a click event handler or
in this case here in the program we
should never do
we should never call this and say well
just give me the result
or wait until all of that is completed
because this is going to introduce some
problems
so instead of doing that we want to use
async and await at the top level or when
there's something that we want to do in
the continuation so this is a slight
performance improvement especially for
iot devices
but it also is good for for mobile
phones and so forth
so if i compile this if it works to
compile this application it says build
failed perfect
but compile only that part
why is this failing
all right
just trust me it reduced the state
machines
luckily i think you have a slide for
that in just a moment
so we looked at async void
uh we'll get back to that improved state
machine in just a moment
but i did mention quite a few times that
you could end up having a deadlock and a
deadlock doesn't necessarily mean that
you wrote some bad a code it just means
that you were either unlucky or you have
a race condition
so i want to avoid this happening where
there's no way to turn back from that
that happening and a
a complex situation where this could
happen if we just look through the code
here
now an issue here
i'm just having a task delay just
imagine that this is any asynchronous
operation i schedule a continuation the
continuation is trying to talk to the ui
thread which is whatever started this
asynchronous operation and then we have
this thing at the bottom here
the weight keyword or the weight method
call that means please block the ui
until all of that code is done but how
could this ever complete
if we are blocking the ui
i don't think anyone would write this
type of code right
this never happens
what does happen is that we write code
that looks like this
which is exactly the same thing
so if we have a look at what this would
look like in our
ui application
if visual studio decides to work again
now if i were to change this up just
slightly to say that well
i want to block the ui until this is
done let's just wait for this to return
a result
i don't care that this is going to
behave slow i don't care that this is
going to be a synchronous call a
misconception is that adding weight or
dot result means that we're running the
code synchronously but that's not really
what happens
now if i run this i'm going to try and
run this with the debugger attached
for some reason this project worked so
let's click run here
sorry
i'm just going to get rid of some code
i don't think it rebuilt the application
now what happens with that when i add
weight here is that it's going to block
the ui application until this
asynchronous operation is done
but now that we know
i'm sorry it's because of this throw
exception here
now that we know
that all of the code here is going to be
moved into a state machine
the state machine is in fact running on
the ui thread
so how can it schedule the call to run
the asynchronous operation how can it
notify us that the asynchronous
operation completed
if we are blocking that original
thread it can't
so hence we're going to have a deadlock
let me try and run this again
and all of a sudden the application
crashed it's not going to recover from
this here because now i've blocked the
ui the task where the state machine can
no longer execute which means it can no
longer report that the task completed
successfully
so of course
we don't want to do this
but of course there's always a way to
fix things that doesn't work so there is
a way for us to force this to block the
application and behave sort of
synchronously and i can think of one
really good idea
let's let's just imagine it's a good
idea because it might not be so what we
can do
what about we let's move that state
machine
and let's run the state machine on a
different thread
let's block the ui
and then when that state machine
notifies that this task is completed the
ui will be notified that that work is
done as well
so now if i run this
we're gonna have more problems but we've
still we we removed the dead deadlock so
at least they got an exception right
that's better than actually deadlocking
the application
now what i'm doing here
some of you might be thinking well now
you've moved all the work to a different
thread how can we now update the ui from
that separate thread well we can't so
now we have to go back and refactor that
and use the dispatcher and so forth and
if we're using the dispatcher again and
we have the weight here how would that
ever finish
so what do we take away from this never
use weight never called dot result but
now you know that the state machine runs
on the thread that runs that
asynchronous method before the
asynchronous operations starts
so nothing in here is asynchronous until
it sees the task that run that's what
schedules work somewhere else remember
all of this code here in the state
machine runs on the original caller
thread
okay
so let's see here
i have a few more things to go through
so to avoid deadlocks never call wait or
never use result and please don't
confuse weight all with task.when any or
when all
and another i guess more
advanced scenarios when you add locks to
your applications you should never share
locks across different threads or for
different purposes because that is also
an easy way to get a deadlock a nested
lock is also a way to get deadlocks in
an application there's multiple ways to
write code that doesn't work it's really
much harder to use this properly
so again i tried to to show you this but
the unnecessary state machines like in
this case here we have all of these
these methods being called and if
there's nothing in the continuation why
would we ever need to introduce the
async and await keywords
so we don't if there's nothing in the
continuation we don't need to await that
and this is true for most situations
it's not true for when you're using
entity framework or web calls for
instance in those cases you cannot just
return that operation or return that
call that has to be awaited in that
context
so then again what does async all the
way means
we want to avoid the unnecessary state
machines but we want to make sure that
we can await everything at the top level
and that would mean that we for example
do it in the click event handler
another important topic is cancellations
how do we cancel an asynchronous
operation sometimes we might have a task
that runs for a very long time it might
be a long running operation that runs or
pulling some data it might be listening
for some stream or something like that
well one of the first things that people
try to do is introduce one of these
things called a cancellation token
source
which you then couple with this thing
called a cancellation token the
cancellation token can be signaled to be
cancelled
now this here is a very simple
application it's called startasync
because it runs or starts an
asynchronous operation which is
simply putting all of the code inside
this long running operation on a
different thread
now the body of this code here is very
very simple
it pulls for some data or we can imagine
that it does it tries to process some
data and then just to have a little bit
of backing off on that thread we're
doing a thread.sleep
so with that in mind if we call
cancellationtokensource.cancel
how would it know where to cancel all of
this work
how would it know what to do with all of
that could it just tear down the thread
would that be appropriate
so when we call cancellation token
source.cancel nothing happens
what we have to do is that we have to
listen for this manually we have to
handle this inside our code we have to
potentially handle rolling back some
data as well to ensure that we're not
ending up in a situation where we have
data that shouldn't be there or half
process data so we can add cancellation
token source that throw if cancellation
is requested that will then exit this
loop and when we call this it will
notify that task that it failed and
whoever's in calling that or awaiting
that long running operation will then
know that there was a cancellation
so we have to manually listen for
cancellations
and i did just mention this but when it
comes to asynchronous database
operations
entity framework does not support
multiple different asynchronous
operations at the same time so you have
to await each call before you're doing
another one
and you should do that in the same
context
as well
now as a final piece i want to talk
about streaming data and if you went to
my c-sharp talk yesterday you saw that
that exactly this demo that i'm going to
show you here how we can listen for
streams of data so imagine that we have
this for each loop here that's trying to
iterate over a bunch of elements now i
can say that i want to retrieve each of
the elements asynchronously that means
that i could get a stream of bytes a
stream of strings a stream of objects
into my application
and it's really rather simple
if you know your way around async and
await now i have this method here called
get lyrics
it's marked as async and it has an i
innumerable of string as a return type
that's a task-like object so you can use
the async keyword together with value
tasks together with tasks and together
with the i async enumerable what this
means here is that
we are going to get a stream of strings
returned back to our application
and then what i have in here is i'm
opening a file to disk i'm reading each
line asynchronously and then just to
show you exactly that this takes a
little bit of time i'm just introducing
a task.delay and then using yield return
to tell the iterator that i have some
data available to process
and to consume this stream of data i can
do await
for each
or a line in get lyrics
this here top level statement isn't
giving me a lot of intelligence
console.writeline
you can write this out to the console
and now
like if you've seen this in the past or
used asynchronous programming in the
past normally we have the await in front
of git lyrics here but that would mean
that we get the entire
the entire stream or the entire chunk of
data at once now what i want to do is i
want to get one string at a time and i
don't really want to start reading the
next string until i process this
completely so if we have a lot of work
in here i don't want to start off
processing the next one until i actually
have everything available so if i save
this here and i go to my console here
into dot net run
hopefully this will stream some some
nice lyrics out to the console
there we go
and it works
so
this here shows us that we can now
subscribe to a stream of data and we get
this
this very nice stream that i can process
it reach each line as it's available in
the file
all right so
with that being said i hope you liked
all of the pretty cool things we've
looked at with asynchronous programming
it is really a complex subject and to
write really efficient code when it
comes to the task parallel library and
async and await it takes time to fully
understand all the gotchas around how it
works and what happens as we saw here
with all the captured exceptions and the
unnecessary state machines and so forth
if you've got some time over after this
i have a four hour course on pluralsight
that goes into detail on each of these
different topics
so hopefully you've enjoyed this and if
you have any questions about
asynchronous programming or anything
like that
you can check out my courses or you can
just ping me on twitter and i hope you
found this useful and now have some
tools to write some more efficient async
and await using the task parallel
library thank you so much my name is
philip beckberg have a great conference
you